this is your one minute notice this
meeting will begin in one minute
good morning everyone and welcome to the
Thursday January 9th meeting 19th
meeting rather of the science technology
and energy committee
to begin our meeting this morning I'd
like you all to rise and join
representative Michael Harrington as he
leads us in the Pledge of Allegiance
thank you representative Harrington
this morning we're here to hear a
presentation from ISO New England our
grid operator
after which
unless the committee keeps the iso New
England Representatives here through
lunch we will have a brief lunch uh
break from 12 to 1 and then at one
o'clock
we'll have a presentation from the New
England power Jenners generators
Association
before we begin this morning however I
have a couple of
uh administrative details to inform the
public about
number one and I'm sure some of you have
noticed this because we've received a
number of complaints the house digital
calendar
is not working correctly
therefore the
the calendar listing on the House
website for this meeting and at other
meetings around the state house around
the Legislative Office Building is not
correct
and
the house administrative Services people
are well aware of this problem they're
working to fix it
but what it means practically is that
you should
maybe not rely on the digital calendar
until such time as we know it's working
correctly and instead
bring up the pdf version of the printed
House calendar to
find out exactly when meetings are going
to happen and what kind of activity will
take place at those meetings
so for example even though you've all on
all the members of this committee have
received a
an email notification of our committee
meetings next Monday and Tuesday
they will be printed in the house
calendar that is printed or that is sent
to every member this evening
so that is the calendar that I would
rely on if I were you to determine when
we're meeting and what we're discussing
during those meetings until further
notice hopefully the digital calendar
will be repaired sooner rather than
later
another issue that's come up is that
last session
house administrative Services developed
a way for members of the public to
submit testimony on bills it uses a
house portal on the House website
and once that portal was determined to
be working correctly
which it currently is
we
the speaker made a policy that we would
not accept
testimony written testimony via email
we only accept written testimony via the
portal
so if you send testimony to this
committee via email
while members may see it and choose to
read it it will not go into the official
record for that house bill
so if you want your testimony to be in
the official record for a house bill you
need to submit that testimony through
the portal
or you can hand deliver that testimony
to the committee at the time of the
public hearing
I hope that's clear and if you have any
questions you can see me after the
meeting and we can we can discuss it
then
I don't want to take up any further time
that we have allotted for a presentation
by ISO New England
I guess we have a question from
representative naughter thank you Mr
chairman I was wondering if you could go
over the rules again on what is
appropriate to say ask asking questions
and as opposed to make just making
comments and
uh
speeches okay I'd be happy to do that so
just to refresh every member's memory
we're here to gather information
we are not here to debate with people
who are presenting to us
we are not here to make comments
about what we're hearing we're here to
ask pertinent questions to gather
information
so that we can use that information in
our decision-making process
so when I recognize you to ask a
question
the first words out of your mouth should
be a question
and if the person that you're asking the
question of needs a clarification of the
question they will probably request it
and at that point you could provide said
clarification if necessary
but we don't want to see
two-minute expositions prior to the
issuance of a question that wastes
everyone's time and doesn't lead to good
answers to questions so think about the
questions you're going to ask
ahead of time and try to formulate them
in such a way as to extract good
information
try not to bias the question by making a
comment ahead of time
we want to get information we don't want
to get we don't want to lead people to
answer is that we hope they will provide
so I hope that's clear I hope that
answers your question representative
okay
so you know other questions we'll move
on and introduce
Kerry schlichting schlitting the senior
police state policy advisor ISO New
England and Kerry please correct my
pronunciation if I got that wrong
and Melissa Winnie State policy advisor
from ISO no England
these young ladies have agreed to travel
up here this morning to present to us
in place of Eric Johnson who is a
governmental relations officer for ISO
New England he contracted covid about a
week ago and he is still in covet
protocol so he was unable to join us
here this morning
these ladies will provide us with an
overview of what ISO New England does
and that we'll be able to ask them
questions to get additional information
so with that I will turn the microphone
over to Ms schlinkding schlichting that
is a slightly difficult name
Kerry's fine thank you okay to Carrie
and Melissa thank you go ahead
thank you all for having us today and
thank you for the introductions Eric
wishes he could be your hair as well but
we are glad to be here and we work
directly with Eric at the iso and are
here to answer all of your questions as
we go through our materials so if it
works for the chair if you have
questions throughout the presentation to
please raise your hand at the time and
we'll address some as they come up
today we're going to be covering a few
basics of about the power system and ISO
New England as well as looking at the
power the markets in the New England
region the work that the iso is doing in
our system planning planning ahead and
looking at what the changing resource
mix and changing energy grid looks like
in New England and then we have a
variety of resources that we have linked
for that are in the Powerpoints that we
will share the electronic version after
this for additional resources
thank you
so I assume New England we in our role
is to plan the transmission grid and
system and administer the Region's
wholesale markets and operate the power
system to ensure a reliable and
competitively priced wholesale
electricity
that's our mission that is the values
that govern our day-to-day activities
and when we think about our vision this
is where we are going this is where ISO
is a collaborator and a stakeholder with
the New England states to help them
achieve their policy goals in the region
while also ensuring that we make we stay
true to our mission and our our course
of reliability in the region so we are
looking forward to what that mean what
the future will look like and how we
maintain our requirements within that
evolving grid
um ISO in New England has more than two
decades of experience overseeing the
Region's restructured electric power
system we are regulated by the Federal
Energy Regulatory Commission for the
ferc in Washington DC
we are the reliability coordinator for
New England under the North American
Electric reliability Corporation and
it's always important for us to
emphasize that we are independent of
companies in the marketplace and neutral
on technology that means that the ice
everyone who works at ISO New England
has divested of any personal investments
in energy companies and Technologies and
it means that we for when we plan and
operate our system we are technology
neutral or fuel neutral we are systeming
what we call economic dispatch which
we'll talk more about but we are looking
to run the power system without any
Prejudice or preference to certain types
of resources
yes may I interrupt you for a quick
question could you clarify the
the difference between ferc and nerc who
reports to who
is ISO New England report to of those
two uh how does that relationship work
ferc is our federal regulator the
stakeholder process in New England to
ferc for their approval and then those
are made so those are our legally
binding guidelines of how we run the
power system we have responsibilities to
nerc as a reliability coordinator that
has a variety of operational
requirements and standards that we have
to meet from an operational perspective
to maintain reliability and those types
of
those are more operationally focused in
when we think about the types of
reserves that we have online 10 minutes
or 30 minutes or the amount of surplus
that or that we have in a day when we
think about ferc they are overseeing all
of our markets development all of our
our budget as the iso all of the
operational aspects that the iso does
across all of our functions
so as a follow-up you do have to get
permission from ferc to do certain
things correct but you don't have to get
permission from nerc nerc establishes
requirements that we have to meet
from an operational perspective
does that answer your question yes okay
thank you representative Thomas as a
follow-up I suspect
thank you not quite a follow-up just
another question along the same lines of
your briefing
um I'm a little confused tell me how how
how do you mean that that ISO is neutral
on fuel fuel how does that work so when
we plan and operate the power system we
do not dispatch any units based on the
their fuel type there's no preference in
order of dispatch it is based on a price
in the market so any dispatch of units
is based on the value that they have
offered into the market system so we
call this an economic dispatch that
ensures that the cheapest less expensive
resources are being dispatched first so
a for an alternative to look at it you
could say that you wanted that all
nuclear generators were dispatched first
and then all of the oil dinners and then
all the wind generators but that would
be a different type of system you'd be
favoring or prefer have preference for a
source where this is all based on the
price that any resource has entered in
to the market regardless of what type of
generator they are
follow-up
thank you Mr for the follow-up
so
in that case then our
all fuel types generators uh
equally uh bidding into the market so uh
there's there's no heavier weight than
one versus another
correct there are different
characteristics of the resources which
allow them to bid certain amounts of
power into the system for example us
there's a solar facility has a different
capacity rating than a Nuclear
Generating facility so there's when
they're entering in their bids they're
allowed to put only so much energy into
their bid based on the type of resource
there are
if that makes sense for example we know
on a cloudy day solar can't bid their
full amount in to the system they can't
be dispatched so there's a capacity
Factor that's applied to the specific
resource
but and we also we know that summer
versus winter different types of
uh generators have different operating
capacities based on if it's really hot
or if it's really cold that can affect
the amount of power that they are
eligible to bid in but once they have
been in at their price the it's they are
just dispatched based on their price
Reynolds this has a question thank you
Mr chairman this is actually following
up on the Chairman's inquiry about
the distinction difference between ferc
and nerc would it be correct to
understand that the ferc is a is the
federal government it's a regulatory
agency of the federal government it is
charged with issuing and enforcing the
uh regulations that Implement federal
law so like the energy Policy Act uh
like other energy
acts laws passed by Congress while
nerc is an industry created cooperative
organization
to uh whose goal is to
support
um
private organizations like yours and
grid operators and our neighboring grid
is of course as people have told us pjm
and so help the industry operate to
ensure reliability throughout
regions throughout the country yes nerc
is more than just ISO New England where
right ferc is all of all of the country
minus some exceptions in the urcot
system because they have a different
type of jurisdictional agreement
for nerc is just as specific subsection
of the country and that based on the
interconnection the ties and the
Reliance on those systems and
um if in a minute we'll move to a
different slide that will show that in a
little bit of a different way but yes
that is a representative a good way to
put it thank you
representative Nutter has a question
thank you what is the most reliable
source of energy
so when we think about the any any type
of generator can go offline or be
unavailable we we see
generators have outages they need
repairs scheduled maintenance
um so any type of generator can be
offline at any time but we work on that
through us we schedule that for any sort
of planned outages through the iso when
we think about reliability it's more of
the the the the commitment that the
resources have made within the
marketplace to provide there's not I
can't say that we're we're neutral in a
way that we we wouldn't identify that
this is the answer versus this is not
the answer of a resource the different
resources have different characteristics
that have different values when you
think about a system operation for
example we have some resources that are
fast start resources they can ramp up
and be online in 30 minutes and that has
a very specific value depending on the
time of day or the type of situation on
the grid where another type of resource
something that's like nuclear they don't
ramp up and ramp down they just produce
a very steady state of electricity so
that has a different type of resource
that they offer to the grid there's some
resources that can do what we call Black
start start from zero turned off all all
the way on and that's another type of
resource so it's really a compilation of
all the different characteristics of
these resources that we can talk a
little bit more about we have in
addition to just our energy markets we
have what we call ancillary Services
where the different generators provide
voltage support and they help with
things like frequency which are
important to the grid from a different
perspective of just pure generation and
reliability capacity
I know that doesn't quite that does not
directly answer what you're asking but
from our perspective I I can't tell you
that the one is superior over the other
because of the way we look at it of a
technology neutral
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman um my question is
actually on the neutrality of rates and
and rate providers and this actually
ties to the the minimum offer price Rule
moper and Casper
um how is price affected by the minimum
office offer price Rule and uh how much
have Advocate State policies influence
the rates that we currently have
if it's possible that I we make a note
of what the moper is and provide a
little bit more background we're going
to go through some of the different
markets that the iso has including the
Ford capacity Market which is where the
moper falls in and if we could make a
note to address that when we get to that
slides if that's all right
representative that's fine kind of
follow-up
yes follow-up just on uh the minimum
offer price rule
um tie to that does it in fact influence
the rate that is charged
the minimum offer price rule is part of
the Ford capacity auction which is run
every year and it it influences the
types of resources that can clear in the
market so in the sense that it is part
of the mecca the market clearing
mechanism which is the value for the the
wholesale price through the capacity
Market it does have a there is an
influence on that but that is only part
of the markets it's not part of the day
ahead energy Market or the real-time
energy Market nor the ancillary Services
markets so while yes it does have an
impact on the values of the forward
capacity auction and what clears in that
it's not related to the other markets of
the iso feel free to wait until you get
to that part of the program sorry I
realized I just jumped into quite a bit
of acronyms thank you okay
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
joining us can you uh describe your your
ownership structure I mean are you a
non-profit are you a corporation and and
what's the composition of the board of
directors
I'm going to just skip to a slide and
then we'll go back to the one we passed
because this directly uh answers your
question I can I can wait okay well is
that is that all right sure right
so before we jump into is it all right
to continue on yes please continue
um
before we jump into our oversight we we
have three critical roles per our tariff
which is our governing body under for
ferc we are responsible for grid
operation so that is day-to-day managing
of the power system keeping the lights
on 24 hours a day we design run and
oversee the markets where wholesale
electricity is bought and sold and we
are responsible for power system
planning and that is studying and
analyzing different generation
interconnection requests and
transmission requests as well as the
system reliability and system Health to
ensure that electricity needs our meat
are met over the next 10 years and we'll
talk more about when we get into the the
forward-looking studies how that role is
even evolving to farther outlooks in the
future
so we have to representative is it
months uh question there are a variety
of entities that have oversight over ISO
New England we are a not-for-profit
um we are overseen by ferc as our
federal regulator we have as well as the
Northeast power coordinating Council and
North American Electric liability
corporation which is nerc as we talked
to for some of the reliability
requirements from an operational
perspective and we have an independent
board of directors which are selected
through an outside search process and
provide oversight to the iso we also
have we are also part of knee pool
um which is the regional stakeholders
which you can see which are the green
group in the center of the slide where
there's different sectors of
participants in the New England markets
that have that participate in
stakeholder meetings for on all proposed
changes to the iso's tariffs and that's
where any sort of change or New Market
design would go through the stakeholder
process and be submitted to ferc for
approval
um we also have we also work with our
New England states in the region we work
with Nesco which is a New England State
Council on a
electricity thanks Melissa
um as well as we work with our cons the
state's consumer Advocates attorney
generals and policy makers like
yourselves the public utility
Commissions in the state's environmental
regulators and energy agencies these
entities do not have direct oversight
over the iso because ferc is our
regulator but we are partners with those
or at least all these different entities
and work with them in our processes and
to make sure that we are transparent and
clear to the states of what where we're
going and why
so representative do you have any
questions again on that
this was brought up earlier we are part
of a larger Grid in New England the iso
six New England states we are directly
connected
um not only to the Quebec CIS power
system but to nyso which is the New
England I of the New York ISO and it and
through the New York ISO to pjm which is
the Mid-Atlantic and Southern States but
electricity electric electrically we are
tied all the way almost to the Western
the Rocky Mountains on the western side
up through Canada and down to the
southern parts of the U.S we are their
exception being ercot which has a unique
structure and is not directly
interconnected in the same way to what
we call the Eastern interconnect
and
the 2003 blackout which did not affect
this part of New England but was
directly felt all in the southwestern
Connecticut was when there was a power
outage in the Ohio region that within 10
10 seconds cascaded Eastward and caused
a power outage all along the Eastern
Seaboard and that level of an outage was
really unprecedented at the time and as
a result in 2003 nerc and npcc
undertook a big stakeholder process to
create a regional set of requirements
for reliability that really emphasize
the communication between the different
isos in the region
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh can you speak
about the implications of the
differences between AC and DC
transmission
sure
this slide here on the next slide shows
our different AC and DC interconnections
in the New England region so AC is an
alternating current and DC is a direct
current that means it has they have
different
characteristics
um
not saying one or the other is preferred
or non-preferred but they we have both
types of inter Corrections in a direct
current means that everything is flowing
in one way at the time and to so it is
possible to switch and gold power back
but it cannot alternate back and forth
so when we have our direct current
interconnections there the power is
normally flowing in One Direction and
for us we have two DC interconnections
in the northern part of our system that
are most almost always flowing from
Canada into New England we also have one
DC connection which we call the cross
sound cable that connects Connecticut to
Long Island
but the majority of our interconnects in
New England to both New Brunswick and
New York are AC connections
follow-up
thank you I'm still unclear uh are there
differences in terms of of transmission
capability I mean why would one be
preferred over another for a specific
application
so I I'm not an engineer but I will do
my best to answer this question I'm
happy to follow up from an engineering
perspective my understanding is that the
direct current allows for larger amounts
of energy to be
uh distributed over the lines where ac
lines are typically smaller sized
systems but that from a their the
benefit or the a pro of an AC is its
ability to switch back and forth and go
back and forth between with where the
direct current is really more of a
one-way Direction
so it's just a pro it's what the the
line is capable of versus a preference
for one or the other
there's a lot of published information
about the difference between AC and DC
continue thank you thank you sorry I'm
best I can do on that one
um but it is to note that
um in the region we do import about 16
of our energy needs
um and our last full data that we have
from 2021 was about 16 and we'll be
getting our new 2022 cumulative numbers
of that
um but the majority of that does come
from Hydro Quebec
across our DC lines
so New England is what we would call a
summer peaking system which is when we
see our highest demand of load on the
system
um and this is this is largely due to
the use of air conditioning in New
England we see the highest amount of
Demand on the the hottest muggiest day
humidity is a large driving factor and
in load
um and that a normal summer day we see
peaks of about 17 000 megawatts to 22
000 megawatts
but that our all-time Regional High for
the summer was over 28 000 megawatts and
instead and we have not seen numbers
approaching that high in the region due
directly to the Investments of Energy
Efficiency and solar PV in the region
those are have been significant
Investments made by the states that have
really reduced the overall Peak and the
overall demand in the region
we have a we have a lower peak in the
winter but different fuel constraints
based on the types of generating
resources that we will speak to more in
further slides
but we do anticipate that in some of our
our work that we are doing on what the
evolution of the grid looks like that we
will switch back to a winter peaking
system in the winter to be a peaking
system in the winter in the future and
that will be due to the electrification
of of heating demand but then all-time
winter Peak was also quite a few years
ago in 2004 at almost 23 000 megawatts
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman
um this is really interesting and one of
the things that jumps out to me is
given economic growth and population
growth in
the region New England
over the last couple of decades why can
you
um
why can you state why perhaps the
all-time Peak Regional demand would have
occurred way back 18 years ago in 2006.
it's it's directly due to the investment
of Energy Efficiency and behind the
meter solar PV and we have a slide
further in the deck that will illustrate
over the how that curve has how that how
those affect the overall demand if we
can come back to that terrific thank you
but it that it I can tell you it is
Energy Efficiency in behind the meter
solar PV
yes correct
all right I'm going to pass it to
Melissa for the next set of slides
great thank you Carrie hello everyone
um so I will be speaking today's tour uh
some more information about our markets
and the power system as a whole
including some more information about
the generation that's currently on the
system and and what we expect to see
coming
um so we have 350 different dispatchable
generators in the region and that uh
equates to 31 500 megawatts of
generating capacity I'm going to talk a
bit more we have a few slides on the
generation that we currently have
proposed in the iso queue as well as a
little bit more information about the
generation that we've seen retire
recently of note here we do have active
demand response as well as Energy
Efficiency participating in our forward
capacity market and and that is in part
due to some changes that were made in
recent years that kind of allow
additional opportunities for those
to participate as capacity in the market
so again I'll provide some more
information on those other bullets in
the next couple slides
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair for thank
you for taking my question uh so this
slide you just just went over
and I perhaps I I misunderstand but
could you be more specific when you say
when you say dispatchable generation do
you mean like Baseline and also when you
say that there's just 31 000 megawatts
of generating capacity is that
dispatchable is it is it Baseline uh can
you further Define those because I think
that's kind of murky there
sure
they're a dispatchable generator means
that the control room can contact that
plant electronically or manually and say
we need you to turn on now so that it's
not like say a solar installation or an
a wind uh plant that they operate when
they can based on the resources that are
available so a dispatchable generator is
something that can be called upon
specifically to respond to the control
room operators so there's many many more
when we think about what is a generator
in the region that's part of our system
that we would not consider dispatchable
there are we are seeing changes to these
types of resources where the future the
the evolution of batteries have really
are going to be changing what we
consider as a as dispatchable there'll
be different types of resources that are
coming online but this is more what you
would think of as
a natural gas facility a nuclear
facility
more of a traditional generator the word
that the term Baseline is the is the
idea they they run all the time and are
available to operation and as a as a
power system we that that notion is
beginning to change because of the types
of resources that are coming online
where in the past it was coal oil and
nuclear and natural gas where they were
kind of always available and the
intermittency of new resources is is
changing how we think about what's
available
but that's that is correct and the
generating capacity includes
all other types of resources like demand
response or active demand or passive
demand response as well as solar and
wind that offer megawatts to the grid
but may not necessarily be dispatchable
in the same way
our Baseline and base load
interchangeable terms yes okay thank you
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh so the 350
uh dispatchable generators what is their
megawatt capacity you have 31 uh 500 for
total including solar and wind and
whatnot but subtract that out what's
available that is a great question that
I don't know the answer to off the top
of my head representative but we will
follow up with the committee afterwards
I just have to look it up in my
spreadsheet thank you
representative closure has a question uh
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question uh dispatchable generators
that had bidded
and they're ready to produce
is there any
this is going to write a liability
is there any information on how many
asks for temporary
offline because of a on
something that happened is that
information available on the types of
generators thank you that's interesting
I am not sure what is publicly available
I know art from an operational
perspective we do have that information
but we are governed by an information
policy at the iso we're we are limited
in the types of information and the
types of identifying information we can
share to prevent any sort of Market
manipulation by competitive uh
generators but if it's something that is
publicly available I will look and see
if I can share
one more question from representative
Doug Thomas
may I just have as a follow-up we do
every day put out information in our
morning reports about
cumulative outages but it's not broken
down specifically by fuel type of or
type of generate if that's what you're
asking so okay thank you
thank you
thank you Mr chair
um on your
subject here on 30 000 megawatts of
proposed generation
realistically
how much how much of that do you believe
will actually get
built
I will just say there is a level of
attrition that happens in the queue
um and so the expectation wouldn't be
for all of the generators and uh
transmission that's in the queue to be
built
um
and if if I may add on to what Melissa
said it depends on it it depends it
varies at some points we've seen as much
as 70 percent attrition in the past of
projects that are looking because many
times these are projects that have
interconnected
one project with multiple
interconnection points so there are
they're looking at hedging from an
economic perspective development which
spot is the best for their a proposed
project or their projects that are
looking to interconnect in hopes that
they'll be picked into a state
solicitation for a clean energy and then
when they're not they withdraw so the
Dynamics of the Q attrition change based
on well Global economics is also a
significant change in how often we see
projects leaving but when for example
a Connecticut issues and RFP for they
just issued one for batteries and we've
seen like
dozens of projects look to interconnect
in the queue in direct response to that
state policy driver so it varies based
on what's happening in the states and
the general economics of the region
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I noticed the the 30
000 megawatts in the queue and you say
it's mostly wind solar and storage and
you know historically never been 100 in
the queue as you just mentioned but
even if half of that gets billed we're
talking about a lot of new transmission
because obviously building power plants
wind solar whatever it is doesn't do any
good if you can't get the power to where
it's going to be consumed now given the
history of New England's recent history
we had um
uh Northern Pass which was you know
hundreds of millions of dollars was
spent and nothing was built we have the
present thing going on in Maine where
they got all their permits and then the
legislature they had a referendum
petition it was overread does the iso
have any plan going forward to try to
work with the states to change siding
requirements so that transmission can
actually be built rather than simply no
one's going to build the power plants
without the transmission
thank you for that question the iso has
no authority over States citing
jurisdiction that's exclusively the
domain of the states so our role is to
do the engineering and technical
analysis that for the interconnection
but in the end what plants are built or
what transmission is built in the states
is is left up to the states
follow up
I I understand that they don't have any
authority to cite regulation site
transmission uh but what I'm asking is
is the iso going to be looking out and
saying okay we're going to be
electrifying a lot we've got this plan
for all sorts of electric cars electric
heat with the demand for electricity is
going to probably in the next 20 25
years they're talking about doubling the
demand so is there a plan to put out
there and say what do we need to do to
get this happen we need to have all
sorts of transmission so to put the onus
back on the states to say you have to do
this or we won't build any of this stuff
yes I thank you for the clarification we
actually have a transmission 2050 study
that we'll talk about at the end of our
presentation that explicitly dress
addresses that question and I would like
to note that from the iso's perspective
and for transmission we do have certain
Authority for a reliability need to have
Pro to request an RFP for transmission
for reliability for the region which is
different from a public policy
requirement to interconnect clean energy
that the states May pursue so there that
is a different avenue which we'll also
talk a little bit more when we get to
the transmission planning system of our
prep our presentation but I've made a
note to come back to that
great may I make a suggestion to the
members of the committee here that many
of the questions that you're asking
right now will probably be answered by a
slide later on in this presentation so
let's think seriously about withholding
your questions uh we're only about a
third of the way through this
presentation so let's let's withhold
some of the questions until we get a
little farther along is that okay with
everybody
okay let's continue thank you
great so I mentioned on the last slide
that
that some retirements of generation
since 2013 we've seen 7000 megawatts of
generation retire or announced plans for
retirement these are predominantly coal
oil and nuclear resources and we
anticipate about another 5 000 megawatts
of the remaining coal and oil resources
at risk for retirement this is in in
part because of the New England states
policies of working towards pursuing
more clean energy rather than continuing
to refurbish these sorts of fossil fuel
generators
um they have these types of generators
have historically played an important
role in uh our winter season
particularly when natural gas supplies
are constrained in the region
um and so that is a
a factor that we need to think about as
these plants retire and how we're going
to meet some of those requirements in
the future
yep
great so this slide here is showing the
types of resources that are providing
electricity to the New England grid this
is for 2021 and you can see about half
is from natural gas resources about a
quarter is nuclear as Kerry mentioned
about 16 percent comes from Imports and
then you could see the remaining 10
Renewables that hydro and a small amount
of coal and oil
um
and we'll talk a little bit more about
how this is continuing to change in the
next couple slides
one point about the region being
dependent
um as we saw about half on on natural
gas is that natural gas is often the
marginal resource in terms of our the
way that our markets operate and so
historically we see wholesale
electricity prices uh tending to Trend
with the natural gas prices and so this
chart here is showing from 2003 to 2022
and the the light blue line is the
wholesale electricity and the darker
blue line is natural gas and this is to
show again you know when you're seeing
natural gas Peaks for various reasons
often in the winter time we often see
wholesale electricity prices Spike as
well
okay
to talk a little bit at a high level
about the markets so we have three
primary markets
the first is the energy market and this
is the spot market for trading actual
electricity production and there's two
components of this so we have a day
ahead energy Market that is looking at
what our projected load is for the next
day and uh looking for resources to
enter the market to bid in to provide
Power for that next day in addition we
have a real-time market so that is the
day of
um and that is meeting whatever
additional load
um isn't met by resources in that day
ahead market so those are both electric
energy real production and those
fluctuate throughout the day they
fluctuate throughout the region for
various uh various reasons
including you know demands constraints
on the system the prices of fuel that
are being used to to meet the load
to clarify that real-time versus day
ahead Market issue
what would cause a real-time market
price of thirty dollars a megawatt and a
day ahead price of a hundred and thirty
dollars a megawatt
so I will begin to try to answer that
I'm not an economist
um but there is some hedging of risk
that happens in the market so you have
both suppliers and those that are
purchasing energy to meet load so it's a
little bit of a economic condition of
just how those players participate in
the market
um there are also things that can happen
in real time that might
um
you know require
resources to come on quickly or to meet
a load that's uh beyond what we had
forecasted and because we need the power
to meet the load at all times that might
cause a real-time market price to be
higher and I'll look to carry to fill in
and to make sure I understand your
question was a high a day ahead high
price real-time low price it could also
that could be attributed to change in in
load What was forecast and what we
actually saw and a lot of that often has
to come with how Renewables are playing
if it was forecast to be a really a
cloudy day and all of a sudden it was a
sunny day and then there's a lot of
solar production that you might see
real-time load prices drop as an
indicator that we need to back down more
of a traditional generator so in New
England we can have negative prices
um and we have different types of
operational scenarios that send that
could if even though the real-time price
was hot the day ahead price was high the
real-time price is low it's a base is
the difference of what the operational
weather could have been that day and the
load forecast and how those things all
differ from the day ahead to the real
time
great thank you
great the next Market is the ancillary
Services Market
um
I'm not going to spend as much time on
this one it's a it's a smaller
proportion of our our markets but this
is to ensure that we have things like
frequency regulation and voltage support
um so these are short-term reliability
Services
um
and then the last one oh yep and those
are regulated by those are some what we
talk about we regulated by nerc as
reliability requirements are are
addressed by these ancillary services
great and the the last Market here is
the forward capacity market so this is
where we will have a forward capacity
auction to ensure that we have capacity
three years in the future
um and this is really to ensure that we
do have generators that will be
available uh online in that three-year
period to meet the load
and so who provides those ancillary
services
any type of generating resource in the
in the system can provide those
resources as you know as long as they
have the characteristics based on their
type of resource
um and this is so we had a question
about the moper the minimum offer price
Rule and the the minimum offer price
rule is part of the forward capacity
it's a rule of the four capacity Market
that has been in place and that is in a
transition out there are two more
auctions so this year's auction in next
year's auction which are still run under
the with the moper in place and then it
is being phased out I mean the the moper
is a way that was intended to
bring in different types of resources
that are traditionally a higher cost
and allow them to participate in the
market and
it has been very controversial in the
region with a opponents saying that it
is limiting the ability of renewable
resources to enter because they of the
the costs that they have
through different processes of a
qualification for the forward capacity
auction
um
I we don't have a particular stance on
that but we have through the knee pull
stakeholder process and through ferc the
iso is eliminating the moper moving
forward
so is the moper realistic when many
renewable resources receive
government subsidies
doesn't that distort the
Market process
that is part of what the role of the
moper was trying
was intended to help
address from a market clearing auction
um
I'm not sure that I'm the best to speak
about the intricacies of the why or why
not the moper did not did not work or
was not intended at that that's really
where our our economists are the most
but if we have I'm happy to get back
with specific answers to the questions
about the about the moper
okay we'll save that topic for another
day I appreciate you're going to spend a
lot of time on that I think yes
yes representative Harrington does have
a question about it though yeah thank
you Miss Jim let me take my question
this will be another one maybe you want
to add to your follow-up list uh you
know in the end of December we had a lot
of days we we looked out we saw 40 of
the generation was oil and most of these
oil plants live off of capacity payments
because they don't run very often as you
saw in your slide there it's like two
percent of our electricity is produced
by oil over the course of a year but on
certain days of the year like the end of
December they were producing a 40 for
multiple days now if the when the moper
goes away and the capacity prices go
down many of these plants I would assume
are going to close so what's the iso's
uh fix for when these oil plants go away
and we have a real cold couple of weeks
in December or January uh two or three
years from now and like I say you can
take put that on your list if you'd
rather and I can address partially I can
address that so there's
I just want to be clear that the the
capacity payments of the forward
capacity Market are are those amounts
are made three years and ahead for the
for that capacity period here of the
year when we look at some of the past
weather in those times the reason that
oil and
coal were running was because from an
economic Dispatch they were less
expensive than the natural gas because
the natural gas system is designed was
designed for Home Heating in the region
so the majority of the gas is under firm
contract with home heating delivery
services to heat people's homes and
businesses so what only whatever Surplus
is left over that is not under contract
is then available for electric
generation and because there are 50 of
our installed about generators use
natural gas the demand and the supply
are just out of line so prices Spike and
because prices Spike from an economic
dispatch the oil and coal are less
expensive and that's in a real-time
Market that that is not part of the Ford
capacity Market they're they're separate
markets and they're different revenue
streams so while they are connected in
the overall operation of the grid we
part of what the studies that we're
doing looking ahead into the future is
what will be the demand be and what what
do we need to think about from a
resource reliability perspective of how
would we meet those types of Demands
when those resources retire and there
are tools that the iso has
for reliability reasons to retain
resources we have a reliability must run
contract with Mystic which is a
generating facility in Eastern
Massachusetts for to keep them online
before they retired for a reliability
reasons so there's there's reasons that
there's actions we can take for
reliability but we can never keep a
plant on indefinitely
any the plants will retire regardless of
you know we could keep them for a year
or two but there's no more that we can
do for that and that's why we do our
long-term planning
to help the mark to identify to the
marketplace what the need will be so
that developers and projects see a
market signal to enter into the market
continue
okay thank you so we just talked about
those three different markets this is
showing from 2008 to 2021 uh the share
of of those Mark the value of those
markets so you can see that primarily
the biggest Market is the energy Market
as I mentioned the ancillary Services
Market is a smaller portion and then the
dark blue on the top is the forward
capacity Market
um
we're gonna move a little bit quickly
through some of the slides to try to get
to all the material in our presentation
I apologize if that's all right we can
always come back at the end with
questions that's fine okay great so just
quickly on the slide I'm just going to
mention that many of the New England
states as I'm sure you're aware are
pursuing uh clean energy requirements
renewable energy requirements and that
is having an impact on the resources
that are participating in our our
markets
uh so this chart here is showing that
the dark blue on the left is 2000 the
year 2000 the generation from each of
these different resource types the light
blue in the middle is 2021 and then the
green on the end is part of a study that
we'll talk more about but this is
looking at the resources that would be
needed to meet the clean energy
requirements in the region in 2040 so
that is a projection not an actual value
and the the key takeaways here are
really that between 2000 and 2021 we've
seen a great decrease in the amount of
oil and coal as we've talked about an
increase in natural gas and then you can
see the remaining but those are the the
two major changes that have happened in
that time frame
um we we mentioned earlier uh that both
Energy Efficiency and behind the meter
solar has reduced um the load that is uh
needed to be met and so you can see here
that Top Line is a projection of the
load from 2022 to 2031 without any
behind the meter solar and Energy
Efficiency the yellow line below that is
showing the load reduction that is being
provided by behind the meter solar and
the green line at the bottom is showing
that reduction with solar and Energy
Efficiency so the difference between the
yellow and the green is the the Energy
Efficiency impact
um
yeah I think those are the the major
takeaways on the slide here
talking a little bit more about load um
so while we are seeing those reductions
from behind the meter solar and Energy
Efficiency uh as we've talked about
before we are anticipating an increase
in the overall load because of the
efforts towards electrification of both
Heating and electric vehicles and so
this is showing our projection out to
2031 of how many more air source heat
pumps and electric vehicles we will see
in the region
understanding that those will overall
increase the load that's needed to be
met
um and there's more information on all
of this in the report that's linked on
this slide
the policies of the New England states
were also seeing an impact on our
interconnection queue and so here on the
left you can see what the
interconnection queue was in 2017 and
you can see about half of so these are
projects that are looking to
interconnect and generate on the the
grid so in 2017 about half of those were
natural gas and then wind and solar and
you can see now that within our
interconnection queue about half of that
is wind followed by battery storage and
then solar and the chart on the right is
looking at the wind specifically and we
can see that most of that is projects
that are offshore and then a project or
the bottom is onshore wind and we're
seeing interconnection requests for that
in Maine
and to add to this the to be part of the
interconnection queue it because we are
a not-for-profit organization it
requires Financial commitment from the
resources to enter the queue you have to
put up a significant amount of money to
move on to the next step to be studied
requires different amounts of financial
contributions so these while they are
speculative and they are attrition these
are serious commitments into the region
that are Financial that require
Financial backup as well when you say
someone has to put up money
do they give it to ISO New England or do
they just create a bond or how do they
it goes to our settlement process where
there's different levels that are
triggered and they the money some of the
money it does come to the iso and that's
what funds the iso staff to study the
projects
so if you've ever been a consultant you
have a project code you'd have a code as
an engineer for a very specific project
that you're studying that you're you're
building your hours to to study that
specific project and they're they are
paying for the interconnection study
yeah
representative gretian has a question
thank you so much thanks for taking my
question
um just a quick question about the
battery storage projects that are
proposed are those mostly lithium ion or
are you seeing a diversity of of
different approaches
um the queue does not specify what type
of battery it is some of that is
proprietary information so we we at this
level it is just made that they are the
type of generating so it's for us at the
public level it's just a battery but I
can tell you those are Standalone
batteries
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman can you help us
understand or I guess unpack the numbers
on this slide regarding battery storage
solar wind and also I'm referring back
to the slide maybe eight slides ago
where you showed that
when you said 7 000 megawatts of about 7
000 megawatts of generation have
retarder will retire in the next few
years but over 30 000 megawatts of
proposed generation is in the queue
mostly winds solar and Storage
right so our aren't the solar and wind
and storage
um integrated so I you know what I'm
getting at is the industry the renewable
industry and more and more incorporating
storage so that they will overcome the
intermittency
uh hurdle
uh yes so we can have projects enter
into the queue as a paired project so
it's a battery paired with the renewable
energy and the way that in this chart
this is broken down battery storage is
Standalone it's just a battery
insulation be it whatever type of
Technology they've chosen to use
included in the Solar number here would
be solar Plus Storage and the same for
when if it was wind Plus Storage would
be the way that they're interconnecting
through the queue is under that General
category we can always I could we could
dig into the numbers and just break it
out to see how much
of that wind or of that solar was uh
paired with a battery resource and get
back to you
sorry thank you that would be really
helpful just to better understand the
the evolution of the grid that we're
seeing and I anecdotally
a couple years ago we saw more of those
types of projects interconnecting
now we see much more large-scale battery
that's Standalone for that are the types
of projects we're seeing we have seen in
the last few years fewer paired projects
representative lewicki has a question um
I wanted to hold this but I think that
we're here now uh how many megawatt
hours of battery storage do we presently
have in uh ISO and how big are they
we have one dispatchable uh battery
storage project which 20 megawatts
located in Maine currently on the system
from a dispatchable resource from a
generating resource I don't know I'd
have to look it up
okay uh follow up please follow up
the other question is it's 20 000
megawatts but how many hours will it run
because without those numbers you it's
meaningless
so I I believe that the project that
that project itself is a two to four
hour storage project but I'm not 100
sure I would have to confirm if that
number is correct and that is a number
that would be that's from their the the
project specifics materials versus from
the isos we can see from in one of our
resources for our data sheets for every
generating resource which there are
thousands in New England that are
non-dispatchable including all the
resources they get a capacity rating
which is based on so 100 megawatt Wind
Farm does not produce 100 megawatts from
that you know it has a rating like it's
a capacity Factor rating to its
generation from an operational
perspective same with solar because of
just intermittency and resources and
batteries have similar types of a
capacity rating but that is a resource
that is public and we could look at
specifically for that specific facility
continue please
um just quickly I'll note here uh I
pulled out the numbers so this is
looking at total proposed generators per
state and I just wanted to highlight the
New Hampshire number it's 858 the
majority of that is solar and there's a
portion that is hydro so just for
additional information
okay we've
hinted at this a little bit in some of
the questions but these resources are
going to require Transmission in order
to deliver the electricity
and so we currently have seven elective
transmission upgrades or what we refer
to as etus these are transmission lines
that are not being built for
specifically for reliability these are
the elective transmission upgrades and
this is they would be able to deliver
about 13 000 megawatts of of clean
energy
and also to note here as we saw a lot of
the generators in the queue are wind
majority of those offshore wind and
those are also obviously going to
require Transmission in order to deliver
power so that is where we're seeing the
types of of transmission within the
queue as well
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman getting back to
the previous slide I just want to get
clarified on this will you have 858
megawatts of and you say mostly solar so
that would be 850 8 megawatts whatever
the part of that is solar but the actual
output would be something around 13.5
percent of that I think that's the
factor that's used in New Hampshire for
solar I would have to look I don't know
I don't know that number off the top of
my head but but it's not 858 it's some
something quite less that's the main
plate capacity of the installation all
right thank you
foreign
I'm going to turn it back over to Carrie
all right so we're going to talk oh
representative munz has a quick question
before we go on thank you very much and
again thanks for coming of those seven
transmission upgrades
um how many of them are
uh would go would pass through New
Hampshire
I don't know that off the top of my head
thank you
and just when I think about that we
would know their the way that those work
of where they terminate I wonder if it's
if we have the information we'll see
what we have available that's that's
public
I want to touch a briefly upon before we
end today about the role of transmission
in the system because we as we've noted
the evolving system is going to require
significant investment in transmission
and it is something that the region has
already invested
significantly in in the past and a major
part of the iso's responsibility is
transmission system planning and this is
uh
we are
required under our RTO and ISO for
regulated tariff to do this type of
planning and we in addition to the
interconnection queue we conduct
transmission system needs assessments
these are based on different regions of
the New England power system so they are
specific for Boston area upper Maine
Vermont Western Connecticut so they're
very they dive deeply into the specific
region of
um the area and look at what any types
of needs are for system upgrades this
can be Transformer upgrades this also
can include things like pole replacement
our transmission system we do a lot of
we get a lot of updates from our
utilities in the region about the
conditions of it polls and different
assets in the region so it's a very
broad part of the iso's work and
one specific part of this is development
of a what we call our regional system
plan which is a 10-year planning Horizon
document
um as I mentioned as a region we have
invested significantly in transmission
since the early 2000s we have put almost
11 billion dollars of investment into
the region from a reliability
perspective and we have about one more
billion planned of investment in
transmission through the next uh through
the end of 2025.
and these are projects that are not what
Melissa was talking about with the
electro elective transmission upgrades
these are projects that are invested in
specifically to meet reliability
standards that the iso is beholden to
and they are allocated across the states
um based on the amount of electricity
demand in the area so Massachusetts pays
for the bulk of this these Investments
and you can see the breakdown across the
remaining New England states
and these investments in transmission
they are
for reliability but they have other
types of benefits that all six states in
the region see as a result transmission
has
dramatically reduced and almost
eliminated out-of-market costs where
um reliability agreements were needed
with generators to provide a weak area
of the grid protection until investment
was upgraded in that region one of those
examples is what I said was the Mystic
reliability must run project which is
one ongoing RMR but prior in the early
2000s those were much more common in an
expensive an expense incurred by the
region
the markets investment in transmission
also allows for power to flow across the
region from where it is least expensive
so that we can maximize the economic
dispatch of the cheapest resources in
the region and that allows
all of the region to benefit from the
cheaper resources and
as we have seen transmission upgrades
we have allowed older less efficient
resources a more expensive resources to
retire because we are able to move power
more efficiently throughout the region
this chart shows the reduction in costs
that the region was paying previously
when I mentioned about congestion and
reliability agreements and what we call
ncpc which is known as uplift is a make
whole payment
um not to dig into these at this time
very deeply but you can see in the early
in the mid 2000s there were significant
costs associated with these types of
agreements and different types of
congestion that the investment in
reliability has really eliminated for
the region
so looking ahead oh
I'm sorry
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman um this actually
ties back to my question I asked earlier
and thank you for answering the part
about the uh the moper
um the other part of that question was
about Casper and increased legal fees I
know against the Sierra Club they're
trying to fight against Casper and also
the uh how much has that increased our
price rates and how much have uh also
state regulations from like Connecticut
Massachusetts and such raise the rates
and how much do we live that here in New
Hampshire being part of I saw New
England
so the
decisions that the states make based on
policies are not part of social sale uh
before you go on before you answer that
question could you explain what Casper
is for those who don't know yes oh
that's good it's not the Friendly Ghost
I'm gonna be hard-pressed to remember
the acronym of what it stands for off
the top of my head
I
I don't remember what that one stands
for so Casper was part of the market
systems that was a goal to create a
substitution auction and to facilitate
clean energy resources making it into
the forward capacity market with the
acknowledgment that they are receiving
subsidies in the forms of
um P power purchase agreements with the
different states for renewable resources
um
any sort of litigation that has to
happen with that is that that is that is
not tied to the iso's billing in in any
sense any sort of decisions of working
through project
um tariff revisions that go through the
stakeholder process is our normal course
of business so I can't I I can't say
that there was a specific cost allocated
with that every tariff revision involves
significant economic engineering and
stakeholder support and that's what we
just that's part of our our operating
plan and any Connecticut's or Rhode
Island or Massachusetts policies are not
part of the wholesale power system are
the costs that the ISO incurs on behalf
of the region is procuring wholesale
power those are power those are policy
decisions made by the states that are
paid by their constituents and are not
part of our our costs
Casper stands for competitive auctions
with sponsored policy resources
thank you
what that means it's a sub that's the
idea of a substitution auction where I'm
a resource and I have a capacity Supply
obligation but I actually want to leave
the market I will trade my resource
obligation to a qualified renewable
energy project to take it from me and
then I will retire
got it thank you
continue on
so I briefly would like to touch upon a
few of the studies that we're looking at
to go forward in the region
one of the studies that we did over the
last two years is called the Future
Grade reliability study and this is a
multi-phase stakeholder study run
through knee pool and requested by Nepal
to evaluate what the 2040 grid could
would look like with significantly more
Renewables and greater amount of
electrification we have hosted a public
webinar on this when the whole thing is
public for the region
um but the the findings of this look at
a variety of different clean energy
penetration scenarios and what that
means from a reliability perspective and
when they're we we would see
constraints or issues on the power
system again this is a scenario based
analysis this is not prescriptive of
what would be but it is a way that the
stakeholders in New England asked ISO to
prevent some information to begin the
conversation of looking farther ahead
beyond the 10-year Horizon what could
the region be looking like and what do
we need to consider now to if we want to
reach that as a region
this is a overview of all a selection of
some of the ongoing studies that we're
looking at to prepare the future for a
future Grid in the one of them is
looking at the impacts of extreme
weather events
another is the 2050 transmission study
which I had referenced earlier and I
have some additional information on
about transmission needs to support a
high load a high renewable future
looking we talked about the reliable
future grid reliability study we looked
at markets Pathways to the Future grid
to evaluate different Market options to
support a renewable heavy grid and that
comes to mind afford clean energy Market
or a carbon price different Market neck
mechanisms that you could imagine for a
future to make sure there's no need for
a Casper or a moper to have a different
approach to have it be a market-based
mechanism versus State individualized
procurement of clean energy
um and then the transmission planning
for clean energy transition was another
type of assessment on a shorter term
more immediate preparations for a future
of high Renewables
I know that's just the highest level
those are all linked we'll provide a PDF
and if you have specific questions all
of these have executive summaries and
high level overviews that are accessible
on those links and that we can always
provide follow-up on
oh representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh
I'm I'm not clear in my mind as to do
you actually own the transmission
Network
that's a great question Representative
no the answer is no we do not the iso
owns no facilities or generating
generators in the region the only things
that we own are our our office in
Western Massachusetts in a backup
control center in Connecticut the all
the transmission and facilities are
owned by the transmission operators or
the generators themselves our role is
just to study and ensure system
reliability so everything else is owned
by separate entities
follow up follow up
just
so the planning that you're discussing
now goes to the local util utility and
they are expected to carry out the the
build out so the planning that we do we
work we are in I so we work with our
local control centers which are six
control centers within the region that
then they work with utilities but the
work that we're doing is not related to
a distribution system that would be the
streets the local your the local power
lines on your streets or in your
neighborhoods or in in the city we're
working at the wholesale level so
there's connections to those uh to those
utilities obviously but we they're not
our part of our jurisdiction because
they're the distribute distribution
companies those types they have
authority to their local Public Utility
Commission
um
what the studies were doing is at the
wholesale level in a regional level that
and these are just
they're they're not prescriptive they're
not to say this must get built right
here right now the way that the iso
works from a reliability standpoint if
we had a reliability need that we
identified via a transmission we would
open a request for proposals and let
different transmission owners generators
battery storage any type of operate
anyone to submit a project to the iso
for public evaluation to then determine
based on cost Effectiveness and
solutions what was the best for the
region so there's a variety of different
levels of authority in that I I hope
that that helps
okay continue please yeah and I as
Melissa makes a good point to note that
these these studies are at on the
request of our stakeholders and
including our states through through
Nesco and through the economic study
process we the iso supports the region
in pursuing these studies that ISO does
not develop the assumptions by ourselves
and present these we work with our
stakeholders and with Consultants as
approved through our the stakeholder
process and all every step along the way
the assumptions the inputs the data are
all reviewed through our stakeholder
process because these studies are are
for the stakeholders and the different
participants in Nepal in the region
they're not for our our use and benefit
in that way
I'm just to be I want to be conscious of
time I have a couple more slides that we
could go through just that talk about
some of the takeaways of these studies
or if you know chair if you'd like us
just have questions okay so this is a
high level takeaway of the 2050
transmission study
and what this shift shows us is a
significant growth in the need for
transmission to meet increased load due
to electrification and
um in the region and we see that
currently the way that there would be
with this increased demand and load that
in the future scenarios that there would
be more instances of transmission line
overload from so which would be a
reliability violation so this type of
study allows us to see where in the
system we could anticipate those types
of reliability issues looking ahead and
where we would need to invest the system
in the system
so it's the first step in a conversation
about what does the future grid look
like it allows us from an engineering
perspective and a reliability
perspective to say here are where
potential issues would be and begin the
so then the next steps of the studies
are
what are potential solutions to those uh
those violations
we also see that we switch to a winter
peaking system as I mentioned we
anticipate this that by
um
2040 that we are winter peaking system
and that by 2050 we see
a winter peak of 57 000 gigawatts which
is significantly more as I mentioned our
current Peaks are in the that we've seen
in the region are in the upper 28 000
megawatts in the early 2000s so this
would this is a significant change and
an important realization for us to start
planning for in the region
and you can see here that there's a
breakdown of the types of load electric
heating electrification transportation
and air conditioning where the summer
has an air conditioning Peak and you can
see that the heating electrification is
the winter the Green Peak which is a
significant driver of that that growth
when we step back we're doing all this
work at all these different studies and
different parts of our responsibilities
at the iso way we see if in our role
that there are four pillars to support
the state's clean energy transition and
that is significant amounts of clean
energy
the need for balancing resources
so those are resources that can respond
quickly and offer different types of
ancillary service characteristics to
provide reliability
energy adequacy so making sure that our
generators have the fuel and energy they
need to run to be available and that we
need robust Transmission in the region
to facilitate this integration of clean
energy as driven by the state's the
majority of the state's policies in New
England
and then the next couple slides are just
um links to different resources that we
have in New England and at the ISO on
about New England and then these are
more accessible via your electronic
handout for additional information about
our most recent strategic plan and
we would like to note that we do hold
what we are known as the CLG the
consumer liaison group it's a public
meeting quarterly for anyone in New
England to join and hear directly from
the iso about ongoing projects and
status updates
um
the New Hampshire consumer Advocate has
been greatly Don cries has been is very
involved in this season on the CLG uh
Coordinating Committee and it's just
another resource that we have and we
move sometimes there they have been
virtual in the past but we rotate around
the different parts of New England to
make them accessible for people in
different areas of the state and
everyone is welcome to be part of that
and
if you're interested we have a an app
that allows you to see the prices and
any system issues in real time to
receive notifications I'm happy to help
if anyone is interested in that and get
it on your phone and as always we'd like
to extend the the invitation for the
committee members to come down to the
iso and have a control room tour
sometime we would love to have you and
have you meet our operators and walk
through the day-to-day operations in
real life and to see the men and women
that are you know keeping the power
running all year long for us
great presentation
and congratulations to you both for
getting it in before noon time we
appreciate that however we're probably
going to keep you here for a while with
questions because I know there are quite
a few so I'll call First on
representative Harrington
thank you Mr chairman I I guess one of
the big issues is going to be the
transmission obviously you spoke quite a
bit about that earlier you talked about
seven etus uh and then you talk about
building transmission for reliability
now I think we understand the
reliability the transmission is tacked
on to each state according to its
percentage of load it's a graph you
showed the etus don't fit into that
category though so how is it going to be
decided who pays for the etus is that
going to be the the generator or are we
going to see States like Massachusetts
coming out and saying well no we need
the the uh Renewable Power therefore
everybody should pay for this not just
the people from Massachusetts or however
the generator how is who's going to pay
for the etus well Massachusetts does not
have the authority to tell the rest of
New England that they should pay for
that for a generator Massachusetts but
they will try
they can as they had enter into a power
purchase agreement with as part of a
clean energy solicitation and they chose
the New England clean energy connect
through Maine and the Massachusetts
residents would be would pay for that
through their bills
um in that type any of the etus would be
paid for through the develop the
developer of the project and they are
looking to interconnect through
state public policy solicitations they
are looking for one of the states to buy
the power that they are offering to
bring in thank you
representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chairman I actually have
two questions
um the first is
um back earlier in the presentation
there was a slide that's on page seven
of the handout that shows the
distribution of
um
electricity sources
gas nuclear Etc
um
too many years ago I worked for a
company that developed and operated uh
questions refuse burning power plants
um and we had two about 200 megawatts of
capacity in New England is that
considered part of Renewables I guess my
first question is are they part of the
pro uh the of iso and secondly is that
considered part of Renewables
yeah the way thank you for the question
we do have some of those facilities in
New England and they are categorized
under this as a renewable as Renewables
which is based on which is not
consistent against all across all states
but this is how in this they are grouped
yes thank you
thank you and my follow-up question is
um do you does ISO have any involvement
at all in the management of renewable
energy credits
no we do not okay thank you
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh turning to your
four pillars necessary to support
successful uh clean energy transition
number three is clean is energy adequacy
is there a number of megawatts that
you're looking up dispatchable power
that you're looking for there
so we every year Melissa is going to
help me we do an assessment for the the
next year about the amount of load that
will be needed ahead of time and this is
part of the forward capacity market so
we do the three year when we do the four
capacity Market we look three years out
how much capacity we anticipate that we
will need to be there so when we think
about energy adequacy we are thinking
about it from
not only that that like sort of
three-year time frame using the forward
capacity Market to secure obligations
but also from a day-to-day perspective
so energy adequacy is not a megawatt
necessarily that we're looking at at
this point this is more of an idea of
when we we've started a process at the
iso when we to look at for example
natural gas facilities
how should they be rated from a resource
adequacy perspective if their fuel is
not firm and fixed should we re-evaluate
the capacity Factor like we do for wind
and solar for a natural gas facility if
they don't have a firm contract so it's
those types of conversations to say that
in the past perhaps this this new this
natural gas facility had a thousand
megawatt just we're just making it up a
capacity in the future should they only
have a with a with a capacity Factor
added in should they really be 650
megawatt project uh facility because of
their ability to procure gas in the
system so it's a reevaluation of some of
the assumptions that we've had in the
past about the types of resources that
are available so that we are better
capturing the real energy availability
and fuel that that they have to provide
to the region so we're reevaluating
parts of what we how we have assessed
things in the past to be better to
better reflect the actual energy
adequacy the energy that they that they
have so that we're prepared in a region
correctly
follow-up follow-up
so okay so I understand
uh assessment of that but
in in the planning for 2050 you have to
at least have some kind of idea of what
uh firm dispatchable power you will need
and so is there any numbers on that yeah
so in on from the 2050 transmission
study we anticipate the winter Peak to
be 57 gigawatts of peak so
if
nothing changed at all that's where we
would be but this study again is it's
pers it
it's not it's it's just a study it's
just an analysis of one potential future
so the it begins a conversation of what
is the composition of of that 57
gigawatts and what are the
characteristics of it and this is when
we begin to talk about the different
ancillary service and types of
characteristics that we are looking for
in types of in a generating resource and
that perhaps they need to change we
currently what we have nine ancillary
Services seven ancillary services that
we use a market for Ireland has over 20
ancillary services in their energy
system that they are valuing and giving
money to to make sure that they will be
there so the idea of Baseline power is
we think is going to change it's going
to be more of a characteristic of
response time so what are the types of
responses that we have within this 57
gigawatt so when we're thinking about
energy adequacy it's what are the
characteristics that the different
generators are offering to this change
system that we need we need things that
ramp up quickly we need things that are
responsive and that those are the sort
of conversations that we're having and
the study goes into more detail about
this some of these studies that
like trade having some trade-offs if you
did all Renewables you may need x amount
of generation installed to you know to
meet the capacity factors that those see
but if you had
a thousand Mega an extra thousand
megawatts of dispatchable generation it
brings down the need for potential
renewable investment way down because
you have a little bit of a buffer in
room so some of the studies get into the
types of resources and the different
the kind of the trade-offs that you
could have within the scenarios which
might be of interest that we can that we
can share but it's not going to be this
is not the answer of what we need
necessarily for 2050 it's the first
study in the process to begin to
understand that system thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh so referring to
the slide that is up there right now uh
so we're seeing that for the winter Peak
uh a lot of that is coming from Heating
electrification and from transportation
and two questions related to that so am
I correct in understanding that the
heating electrification is primarily
heat pumps
yes this is this is studying heat pumps
replacing gas and oil burners okay and
then for the transportation is that
taking into account that there's often a
flexibility about when you're actually
going to be charging and that you can do
that off peak so
the level of this study we we talk about
some of the assumptions about that of
ability and the different scenarios I
believe have different
some of them look at some of that but
the detail of that
uh two-way charging Demand on the grid
at this study is not the it's not part
of the actual
it's not as much of a factor it has to
be assumed to be a pretty low level at
this point because we don't have any
policies or procedures in place for us
to
to use as examples yet we anticipate
them coming and this is going to be part
of the conversation but again at this
point this is a higher level assumption
about the inputs so it doesn't quite
satisfy your question but it is
something that we are aware of
um and looking we will reap a part of
the conversation moving forward
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um
this question goes to the um
I guess granularity of the visibility of
iso iso's visibility in the forecasts
and in the
information that you you're reporting
to us
um for what I mean by that again
referring back to the slide that was
page 12 where you say what's in the
interconnection queue
and for there's it's in yellow so really
hard to read but apparently about four
thousand almost four thousand megawatts
of solar are in the interconnection
queue
um and sort of relating that to the much
later slides with expected demand Etc
does the 4 000 megawatts in the
interconnection queue how how low does
that go in other words does that include
the expected installations by businesses
and homes of Distributing the wholesale
power system so where we have
jurisdiction as the iso that would not
include solar looking to interconnect to
your local Distribution Company or so
something like on someone's rooftop
those are solar insertions that we have
no visibility in the iso does not have
visibility to the local distribution
companies
system in that way we partner with them
to understand where that solar is being
installed because we don't see it as a
generation resource we see it as a
reduction in demand so we work every
year we update a 10-year forecast for
the P solar PV that includes behind the
meter solar and we work closely with the
New England states and the utilities to
best capture the data that they have so
that we can use that in our forecasting
but it's a big part of what our
forecasting team does not only in the
long-term forecast but for the day ahead
in the real time forecast because that
the the level of behind the meter solar
penetration and the way that the cloud
cover moves across New England is a big
part of our daily forecast
follow up okay yes so again stuff
following up on that
on that answer you're saying that
significant
behind the meter solar generation
something like the megawatt at North
Conway water Precinct or the megawatt on
the roof across it America
Associated Grocers of New England or 600
kilowatts on Oyster River Middle School
those are not
visible to you at the iso in this
forecasting way they seem to be visible
in in hindsight in the craft that you
showed EE and solar has reduced demand
so if those any of those entities were
have that have sold are participating in
the wholesale energy markets
then we do see them so if they have
decided to be part of a RFP or that
they're looking to get money from the
host at which you you could then they or
through an aggregation there's different
ways that they could participate and if
they did then we would have more insight
they're not dispatchable in that way
but like so if I put solar on my house
the iso would never see it nor know it
but my local utility would have that
information and then they would
aggregate that information at the county
level and roll that up and provide that
information to the iso and I would like
to note that the isoq is all public
information anybody here could download
it it doesn't have project names it has
Q identifier numbers so there is some
limit to what is public and from the
emission but from the iso's perspective
all projects looking to interconnect
into our system is made public and
updated regularly
okay representative Doug Thomas has one
final question
it could be a doozy too uh just there
has been a lot of talk
around so my question is what would be
the implication the obstacles for any
state that wanted to detach itself from
the grid and not be a part of say any
ISO organization
sure so first the states of New England
themselves are not part of the iso it's
the transmission operators within the
states that are have entered into an
agreement with the iso as approved by
ferc so
we have seen States in New England think
about the leaving the iso and retaking
resource adequacy and retaking a lot of
the work that we do at a regional basis
back to to have ownership
for their own State
um Maine has looked at this Connecticut
has looked at this and both of them in
their assessments came to the conclusion
that the benefits that the states
receive from Regional investments in
transmission and the economic dispatch
across state lines have more benefits
than
it leaving makes sense that being said
there is no re there is just no
blueprint in New England or any state
that I'm aware of anywhere in the region
in the country that has left an ISO
there's no blueprint for what that would
be
so in theory and the estate would need
to coordinate with their transmission
operators to propose to ferc that they
were leaving and then would need to be
able to demonstrate that they would
still be able to meet the reliability
requirements of their interconnected
Regional grid
that the iso is currently mating on
those behalfs so
it's just a big unknown we don't know
what that would look like or the
necessarily process is because it's
never it has never happened
well we would like to thank both of you
for making the long Trek up here and
doing since an excellent presentation
and answering our questions uh
authoritatively we really appreciate you
being here you did a great job
and I will be sure to let Eric Johnson
know that
and we have a long list of follow-ups
that we will make sure that we get back
to you about and again if there are
additional questions Melissa and I are
happy and with Eric to help answer
questions at any time and we would like
to again thank you for inviting us chair
and having us with the committee and
reassert that we'd love to have you come
down to visit the control room in ISO
well thank you and uh
before we break for lunch I want to
alert the committee to the fact that as
I mentioned at the very beginning of
this meeting our digital calendar has
been messed up for some time now
and it's possible that the New England
power generators
saw that our meeting today was canceled
and may not show up I've sent email to
my contact
uh Molly is here yeah I saw her she's
here she might just stepped out of the
room so great okay good good to know
thank you all right so we will return
here then at one o'clock for a
presentation by the New England power
generators generators Association till
then we're in recess thank you
okay everyone this is your one minute
warning we'll start this meeting again
in one minute
okay let's resume our meeting this
afternoon and
the final section of our meeting today
will be a presentation by the New
England power Jenners generators
Association so I'd like to invite Molly
Connors and Dan Dolan to the presenters
table
now you have passed out some slides did
you want to project them on the screen
uh no Mr chairman they're really just
here for the uh for background we're not
planning to walk through them in any
great detail although we're certainly
happy to to get into any of the
information there if if folks have
questions for them okay thank you
Christy you may want to turn those off
for us thank you
okay so uh take it away tell us who you
are and why you're here what you're
going to present great thank you Mr
chairman and and it's good to see
everybody here uh my name is Dan Dole
and I'm the president of the New England
power generators Association I'm here
with my colleague Molly Connors we
represent uh the companies that own the
vast majority of power plants both here
in New Hampshire as well as across the
Six States of New England within that
membership is uh virtually every
different Fuel and Technology type that
produces electricity today in the region
across that board will keep such a a
wide diverse set of companies all
together is a belief in an open
competitive wholesale electricity
Marketplace in which they're all able to
compete on an equal and Level Playing
Field as long as they're following the
market rules set out by organizations
like ISO New England as well as the
estate policies and procedures that that
are established for the the sighting and
operation of of power generation
facilities within their their territory
as we engage in some of these
discussions where you most often hear us
is in discussions around what does it
take to sustain a competitive
Marketplace how do we ensure that that
we've got an equal and Level Playing
Field and how do we meet the The three
principal goals that these markets have
of reliability affordability and an
increasingly clean electric generation
Fleet to serve consumers getting that
three-part balance right is the hard
part and it is uh there is no single
resource that
immediately serves all of those needs
and it is where we then see the
diversity of the fuels and Technologies
come into play now to to take a little
bit of a a step back uh the the industry
and the group that we now represent
um was accelerated and enhanced
um by New Hampshire really becoming the
first state in the country to
restructure its electricity industry uh
nearly 25 years ago and what that means
is moving the power plants out of
utility rate based ownership in which
all the the costs for development and
operation of those facilities are
recovered directly through rates and
instead going into third-party companies
who have to now compete against each
other every day in the energy markets to
make sure that they can provide the most
efficient product for for consumers
overall within that you then see winners
and losers across the marketplace we see
plants go out of business fairly
regularly we also see new developments
come in and different types of companies
taking over and different fuel mixes is
then of all services that can be
delivered on the most cost effective
basis possible
from that clearly electricity is a
volatile commodity I know you all hear
that from your constituents particularly
these days probably more than over the
last several years but also in in some
of the the charts that we do have in the
presentation you see year to year
fluctuations in wholesale electricity
prices and yet what I think is also
clear is that over the last 25 years
since restructuring and since the iso
New England markets that we operate
under really took hold in the early
2000s we see a clear and consistent
trend line of increases in efficiency in
the operations of the facility leading
to lower costs and ultimately then that
efficiency also having major
environmental benefits both in the form
of emissions from Individual facilities
as well as the fact that today
it takes three plants to produce the
same number of electricity that 25 years
ago used to take four where we're seeing
those efficiencies really take hold and
so my argument is that over that long
term taking the the step back we see
enormous value from the competitive
Marketplace overall the the last item
I'd I'd note is that clearly today we
are seeing a refocusing not just in New
Hampshire but really across New England
around these issues of affordability and
reliability and I I think that provides
an opportunity for groups like this to
help provide policy Direction and
Leadership to the companies that we
represent to ISO New England and the
other players that that engage in the
electricity Market overall we have a
responsibility to make sure that we are
meeting the obligations set out and the
reliability criteria as set forth by the
government as well as then how the
markets get administered by ISO New
England the markets are not perfect they
are evolved loving they need to be
improved and our hope is now we can take
this as that opportunity to refocus and
highlight those important areas with
that uh certainly happy to get into any
of the specifics that are embedded in
the presentation here we hope to be in
front of of you all many more times
throughout this session and certainly
happy here to to answer any questions we
can
uh one quick question could you help us
put us in context this morning ISO New
England told us that there were 350
generators in their Marketplace how many
of those generators are members of N E
PGA
so we look at it less in terms of an
absolute total of uh number of
facilities and More in terms of the
share of the actual generating capacity
because what you see is so uh there are
dozens if not hundreds of very very
small facilities which we may not
represent what we do represent are the
vast majority of what are called the
utility scale or larger scale facilities
think hundreds of megawatts in in
generation capacity
then what you also see is certain
companies have aggregated a number of
much smaller scale resources whether
that's Hydro facilities particularly on
the the Connecticut River here as well
as some of the newer renewable
facilities solar and and wind facilities
that tend to be smaller scale in nature
then get aggregated into a larger scale
portfolio and with that we represent
approximately 90 percent of the electric
generating capacity in New England
thank you all right let's uh open this
up to questions from the rest of the
committee representative Doug Thomas has
a question
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question uh yes you opened
up a lot of possible questions with your
opening comments
um I'll go to one question or one
comment that you made previously about
keeping the cost down so my question is
what is your Association and what are
the power generators doing now to try
and keep down the cost of the really
rocketing price of electricity which I'm
sure if our consumers heard your opening
statement they would not agree that the
prices are have been coming down so what
are they doing and what can they do in
you know in that respect yeah and and to
be clear we certainly recognize that
over the last year the prices have gone
up there's no disputing that and and we
see that largely because uh we have seen
the the fuels and the inputs for
producing the actual electricity have
also skyrocketed largely driven by the
geopolitical forces that that we all see
across the Atlantic in terms of what are
the actions being taken now we are
seeing facilities trying to engage in
more hedged fuel procurements
particularly really for natural gas and
oil to create more stability on that
side of the market we're also in active
engagements with each individual State
about how the default energy rates are
are procured right now New Hampshire
like many of the other New England
states buys the bulk of its electricity
in over one fairly narrow discrete
period of time over about a six-month
Horizon and then locks that in for
another six months that creates then a
lot of volatility when we go from one
procurement cycle to another there are
other ways to try and smooth that out
you can purchase portions of your
electricity in any let's call it three
six or nine month chunk and then ladder
that in to smooth out the ups and downs
the challenge with that is given the
high cost and the inflationary
experience that we've had over the last
years that also means that when prices
do fall they fall slower because you're
smoothing out not just the UPS but the
Downs which is largely what gave rise to
the policy to do the procurements as as
they're structured today overall we're
also seeing a reinvestment occurring in
the facilities to be able to operate
particularly during the winter months
and during heightened periods of
reliability need and the hope is that as
we see more facilities being able to
provide those Services during the peak
periods overall that creates more
competition and lower prices to make
that meet that Peak demand
follow-up follow up thank you for the
follow-up so uh you mentioned the word
policy a couple of times are to be clear
are are you referring that there might
be some State policies that could be
enacted to to help that situation or or
did I misunderstand you on that uh no
not at all uh right now we're not
calling for any state legislation on
that right now the the puc along with
their counterparts in other states are
investigating what are the procurement
practices to the degree coming out of
that there is a requirement to provide
more direction or
more flexibility coming out of state
laws at that point we would be back in
front of you but today we are not asking
for any uh meaningful change in state
legislation
representative munz is recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
very much for coming in
um could you comment on the uh the 800
percent increase in transmission rates
since 2004 what's driving that sure uh
and so um and for those following along
here uh uh that is on Slide Five and
um what we've seen is the utilities post
restructuring have gotten out of the
business of owning and operating
facilities they now own and operate the
transmission and distribution networks
those are effectively the roads and the
bridges on which we deliver our our
product a lot of that is aging and
rightfully needs to be replaced it also
was coming out of a system in which the
vast majority of the transmission
network was was very localized the the
term of art we use in the electricity
industry was a hub and spoke system and
from that there was a limited
capabilities to trade power very
effectively between utility service
territories and across networks across
state lines and so over the last couple
of decades we've seen a concerted effort
to improve those interconnections reduce
what we call a congestion on the
transmission lines and same thing as as
on a highway open up create more Avenues
to be able to deliver power and
ultimately provide the lowest cost
resource across a wider footprint all of
that is to the good and and write an
appropriate investment on that that side
of the system however I also think that
one of the unintended consequences that
we've seen coming out of restructuring
is that the only place now for utilities
to earn higher revenues is in the
investment on transmission and
distribution on those polls and wires
and in a system in which they are
virtually guaranteed anywhere from eight
to twelve percent rates of return for
every dollar spent I think there is a
natural incentive
for driving more and more investment
there and part of our concern and reason
for highlighting it here is that when we
look at the overall Bill impacts and and
the costs that have increased for
Consumer uh over the period of time we
see that portion of the bill
consistently rise in a way that it
hadn't uh up until this point
and frankly deserving of sharper
oversight and and consideration
follow-up
blow up
um can you put any kind of
um estimate on how much of the 140
dollars currently
was due to you know this um
let's just say desire for profit
I unfortunately cannot give you a
straight answer on that one I I don't
know
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Dan it's nice to see
you again
um there's been a lot of discussion I've
had talks with you and this in the past
about what's going to happen and after
post Mystic now we know Mystic I guess
is scheduled to close they're an RMR
plant now excuse me
a year from next spring I guess and that
leaves us with the district gas facility
where about 60 percent of their product
is sold to Mystic so that goes away uh
that that market goes away for them can
miss can the district facility stay and
if it doesn't I believe that just leaves
us with uh canaport and in the offshore
terminal both are very limited in the
amount of LNG they can provide so what
what are the options for LNG post when
after Mystic closes
sure thank you and and good to see you
representative Harrington uh and for the
the benefit of the group
um uh the Mystic power plant is located
in Everett Massachusetts just North of
Boston it is the second largest power
plant in all of New England and natural
gas
um fired plant that uh is one of the
most unique facilities in the United
States because it is co-located with a
liquefied natural gas import facility
um which historically has been called
distrogas for years and years and years
these were two separate facilities owned
by two separate companies more recently
they have been purchased by by the same
company Constellation Energy
and uh several years ago
constellation announced that the Mystic
power plant was no longer economic and
sought to retire the facility now in
power generation unlike just about every
other commodity uh in that exists in our
account economy you don't get to just
decide to close uh there there is a a
regulatory and a market process that has
to go forward and ISO New England
determined that the Mystic Generating
Station was necessary for reliability
and so Mystic is now in um in the middle
of a two-year what's called reliability
must run or cost of service contract
specifically for reliability part of the
impetus for that was to sustain the
operations of the LNG import facility of
which Mystic is Far and Away the largest
single customer that contract with
Mystic expires on May 31st 2024
and there is massive uncertainty of what
happens after that ends what I I do
believe and certainly my organization
supports and I hear a broad consensus
across the market is that the power
plant itself for electric reliability
will no longer be needed
to sustain operations
the discussion then quickly flips well
what happens to distr what happens to
that Everett LNG Marine Terminal and
there is a broad belief that for a
combination of natural gas reliability
on the gas utility and natural gas
Interstate pipeline system and to
provide gas to serve other power
generators across the region that it may
be necessary for reliability and then
the question is what do we do and so I
can tell you this is one of the most
active conversations that we are having
right now with ISO New England with the
individual states we're having
conversations with the sununu
administration as well as now the Healey
Administration in Massachusetts around
much of this
I do think that to the degree that a
solution is necessary for the LNG
facility it does come back to this
combination of natural gas and
electricity on the natural gas side that
LNG import facility is providing
pressure Services essentially making
sure that there's enough gas on the
pipeline system that the flows that
traditionally come west to east can come
in being able to refill the pipeline
system east to west keeps the pressure
on the pipeline going high enough that
you can actually flow more molecules on
onto the the network overall those
reliability services today are not
compensated they are being taken for
free by the natural gas pipelines and
the local Distribution Company the the
gas utility Network outside of Boston I
think that's not right at the same time
we also recognize that there is a
heightened premium on winter electric
reliability and as part of that the LNG
as a fuel for natural gas fire
generation
serves as as a really attractive swing
resource that can be there for those
Peak periods right now that what I call
more premium electric reliability
service is also not fully compensated in
the market and so I think it's this
two-pronged approach on the one hand
working to have the the gas industry
compensate for the services that they
receive and that are necessary for the
reliability on the gas system while also
working with ISO New England and others
to modify the electricity Market
particularly around how we how we credit
the reliability Services of individual
types of power generation facilities
that can then facilitate individual
power plants Contracting for some of
that gas commodity that may be necessary
on the electric reliability end but
representative Harrington as you pointed
out time is short on all of this and um
the solutions are not simple and they
require fairly novel coordination across
industries that as much as I think the
public links
natural gas and electricity is Just
Energy and and of course we talk to each
other
these industries have grown up very
separately and do not always play very
well together and right now uh we have
to we have to get this right and we are
focused very much on doing it so I
apologize for the very long-winded
answer but wanted to provide that
context follow-up no no thank you that
was the answer I was looking for was a
complete one thank you very much you did
mention about being compensated for uh
electric generators were you talking
about generators have got firm gas that
they would be like paid some kind of a
bonus for having firm gas and if if
that's what you're referring to would
that be covered under the new winter
reliability program it's starting in two
years or I guess so
um uh yes to the first part of the
answer which is to firm up that that
fuel supply
um and and create more of a capability
for operational certainty that
um in those type periods you can really
call on each of these individual
facilities the compensation we're
looking at is actually through the
forward capacity Market the the auction
that happens once a year for a
commitment three years into the future
it would be through there's an uh over
the last year we've been working with
ISO New England through a process that's
called the resource capacity
accreditation improvements RCA and it is
through that where we sharpened the
reliability criteria of individual
facilities and and then allow more of
the cost for this type of a a premium
fuel purchase to be recovered in that
market
thank you
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman
you indicated Great Value was seen in in
the competitive market for uh these
wholesale uh
supply of of power and you also
indicated there's room for growth uh so
could you articulate some of those areas
for room for growth and whether or not
there might be incentives or
opportunities for legislation to further
facilitate that yes thank you for that
so one is this resource capacity
accreditation we need to sharpen how we
value the the reliability services that
are being provided a a second product is
that we have seen a a huge growth in
recent years in uh the amount of more
weather dependent uh generation sources
on the system this is everything from
rooftop solar to the really large solar
facilities to win farms and they provide
a lot of value for some of the the
services they provide they also create
different requirements on the system in
particular in the moments in which
unexpectedly they they are not able to
perform because of unforeseen weather
events it is then the the capability to
turn on and off really fast to backfill
that
um that is something that today uh the
market is not well designed to help me
to integrate those those facilities a
little bit better
um it's essentially holding more in
reserve that can quickly come online
that type of a reserve product is kind
of next in line in our discussions and I
think will help facilitate the future of
this Market a lot the third major area
is then
um one of the items that's been
um one of the the frankly most
existential issues we've faced in these
electricity markets where for the last
25 years we've relied on these daily
energy markets and these you know once
annual capacity auctions to drive the
financing and development of facilities
in recent years however most of the New
England states have started pursuing
individual multi-decade contracts for
individual types of facilities and here
you can think of Canadian Hydro offshore
wind onshore wind a lot of resources
that have been chosen through bodies
like this across the region to try and
and bring into the market in a way
that's not happening today on a on a
purely economic basis the the challenge
with that however is by having
essentially a a bifurcated system where
one part of the system benefits from
state-backed 20 30-year contracts and
the rest of the system has to live and
die in these daily markets uh is it is
shrinking the amount of potential
revenue for those other competitive
resources many of which like Mystic may
still be necessary for reliability but
aren't able to recover enough costs what
we I think the the next big challenge
for the region and and for bodies like
this is to figure out how do we better
integrate those State policies for
individual resource types more directly
into the market in a more sustainable
competitive market structure we haven't
gotten it right yet and there are
different solutions to that but it comes
down to what are the policy choices
driving those long-term contracts in a
state like Massachusetts it's largely
being predicated on decarbonization well
as a markets guy I then say the solution
to that is uh price carbon in a
meaningful manner to drive any of these
Investments that you want and then
discipline the rest of the market
if however the policy is driving some of
those procurements are something else
then we need to articulate exactly what
that is and figure out if there's a
product that then can again be embedded
into the Bro the market uh more broadly
it's a really hard thing to do but
that's to me the next big hole in the
market that needs to be addressed
thank you so much thanks for taking my
question
um I wanted to go back to something that
you said when we were talking about the
increase in transmission rates you
mentioned that utilities have a
guaranteed rate of return on these
Investments um can you speak a little
bit more to where that guarantee comes
from
um and where the money comes from
absolutely and and
um uh I I want to uh make sure I'm I'm
clear on this one it is a and if I
didn't say this at the beginning uh my
apologies a virtual guarantee there is
still a a regulatory process through
that but
um that comes in in two forms one is on
the distribution side of the system that
is fully regulated
um by each state in their regulatory
body in New Hampshire it's the puc
through that as long as that facility is
used and useful and seen as a prudent
investment on the system uh the costs of
that are then recovered under rates
and a what is seen as a a reasonable
rate of return put in place
historically that again has has ranged
more or less 8 to 12 percent
we see the higher end of that that
Revenue side come actually on the
federal end where going back to the
energy Policy Act of 2005 passed by
Congress there was an explicit policy of
the United States to try and encourage
more transmission investment
that then set bonus points for revenue
and recovery of of those large
Investments
again all of that makes sense we need to
invest in infrastructure particularly
aging infrastructure in this country
however I think that the concern becomes
as as we are now in year 18 of of that
policy to what degree is that still
appropriate or not and to what degree is
there any competition for those types of
resources or not and here to me you know
the starkest part of that graph that
that
is why we put it in here is the
exponential growth that that we have
seen
and a uh a concern about what that means
on transparency on electric rates
because we do hear so often concerns
about bills and and consumer impacts we
just want to make sure that it is
transparent
uh okay who's next uh representative
Munn's representative Summers rather
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um this has to do with what you just
mentioned there earlier about future
capacity and I asked this advice on New
England actually this morning as well
but with the uh have you seen an
increase in price or at least a floor to
the price caused by uh moper uh the
minimum offer price and can you explain
what if it is and how it's been affected
sure
um uh so again if if you'll bear with me
I'll give a little bit of the context of
of moper the minimum offer price Rule
and then and then uh try to answer your
question so uh the minimum offer price
rule
um is a a rule in place in the the
forward capacity Market that that annual
capacity auction usually held in
February
um for three years into the future what
it is designed to do is ensure that
facilities that do have an outside
Revenue stream guaranteed by a state
like those long-term contracts I was
speaking about earlier that they are
bidding what is seen as their true
economic costs into the market and put
them on a relatively equal footing for
with all the other resources that do not
receive that same in my word subsidy or
outside Revenue stream that that is
guaranteed by a state
what the minimum offer price rule then
does is say for
a Wind Facility or a gas plant or a new
any other type of facility that has that
Revenue stream here is what we believe
is your economically Justified price
if you as an individual facility believe
that your economic price absent that
outside Revenue stream is actually lower
you can demonstrate that you can go to
the market Monitor and demonstrate that
so it is not a it is not a floor it is
not a block it is a screen through which
they must pass if they can can go lower
um however the the ultimate impact of
that has been that for a number of of
resources that do have an outside
Revenue stream a subsidy
um their their capacity Market offers
have been higher because with that
Revenue stream they would likely be
what's called price takers in the
capacity Market they would be
indifferent to whatever Revenue they
receive in in the capacity Market
because they make all their money
somewhere else and so that has meant
that for many of those resources they
have not been selected as the most
efficient economic resources in that
market
through that the criticism has been from
many that that moper the minimum offer
price rule has has propped up capacity
prices and kept out certain resources
from being recognized in the capacity
Market I will tell you I do not share
that belief but my belief
uh put aside moper's going away
um and in fact uh this year's capacity
auction is is the first in which we see
an unwinding of mober so this year
um uh I believe it is 300 megawatts of
subsidized resources will not have to
pass through them the mober screen for
any resources Beyond those 300 megawatts
they still have that screen in place
then in next year's auction 400
megawatts do not have to go through that
screen get what's called a moper
exemption plus any unused megawatts from
this year so 700 megawatts total between
the two years and then finally in the
auction that is to be held in February
of 2025 that will be the first in which
we have no moper whatsoever and it is in
that market in which the expectation is
that any resource regardless of whether
it has an outside Revenue stream or not
will be able to all offer as low as it
would like however there will still be
substantial oversight and mitigation as
to how high they can bid
I hope that answers your question
yes thank you
representative munz has a question
thank you very much I'd just like to
follow up on that
um you know you you mentioned several
times outside revenue streams subsidies
has there been any work done to identify
uh the extent of these outside revenue
streams by
source of generation
the short answer is yes the longer
answer is it's very complicated so there
are the direct
subsidies and outside payments that take
the form largely of long-term contracts
mandated by individual state state
governments that are then implemented by
the the state utilities collectively
across New England the expectation is
that over the next several years of the
roughly 28 000 megawatts of electric
demand in New England roughly 10 000
megawatts of that demand will be taken
up by these long-term contracts that
that are mandated by state governments
there is of course the the next level of
of subsidy that happens further Upstream
for individual fuel technology and
resource types that largely happens at
at the the federal level um and that's
where I I know that accountings of those
have occurred I do not have uh those
numbers handy with me right now
follow-up follow-up
um yeah I think you were getting it what
I was trying to get at I think at the at
the last there I mean I guess what I'm
what I'm wondering is there anything
that says
um uh Power generated by gas has this
kind of subsidy power generated by
nuclear has this kind of subsidy you
know wind Etc
I am confident that that analysis exists
but I do not have it with me
representative Harrington has a question
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question getting back to the
forward capacity Market I'm trying to
remember how this all works again and
I'm not quite sure but how is it are
they different types of resources
treated differently by that I mean uh
let's say a dispatchable resource bids
says I'm 100 megawatts and then if they
called on to deliver the 100 megawatts
they have to face the pay for
performance and if they don't pay uh
they don't deliver 100 megawatts they're
going to get penalized now what about an
intermittent resource let's say 100
megawatt nameplate wind maybe they bid
in 30 megawatts but since it's
intermittent are they treated the same
way in the forward capacity Market
so for each individual power plant or or
generating resource they have their
capacity Supply obligation that is the
amount that is being relied on from a
reliability standpoint and that is what
the forward capacity Market is it is our
most fundamental reliability market so
for a facility under this example that
let's say it's it's name click plate
capacity is a hundred megawatts but its
capacity Supply obligation the portion
of that facility that was selected in
the forward capacity markets is only 30
megawatts then the market is only
counting on it for those 30 megawatts
and any amount that it it doesn't
perform above those 30 let's say it only
delivers those 30 megawatts during a
shortage period or a very stress period
on the market no it is not penalized at
all it is seen as having met its
obligation in the expectation of the
market however for a facility that
clears all 100 megawatts of its 100
megawatt capability and has a 100
megawatt capacity Supply obligation but
they only deliver 30 megawatts during
this stress period of event then those
remaining 70 megawatts are penalized and
penalized severely for their
non-performance their their inability to
be there
follow up like I guess I'm trying to
figure is on let's concentrate on the
wind the 30 megawatt so it was 100
megawatt nameplate 30 megawatts it's
capacity Supply obligation was 30
megawatts but on any given day maybe
producing 60 megawatts 70 megawatts and
another day it's 10 megawatts because 30
is the average so we have a day where
the uh pay for performance comes into
effect and the wind is only delivering
10 megawatts on that day are they judged
on how they deliver on that day or they
do judged on some type of an average
so with respect to how much is um uh
selected under the forward capacity
Market it is the average it is
um that that's what they are accredited
from a capacity standpoint in terms of
penalties under uh the the pay for
performance structure as it exists
um they are then only judged by how they
perform on that day and and it is
actually coming back to that broader
averaging that how do we actually
designate how much the market should
rely on an individual facility on an
individual resource type that's exactly
the issue we're trying to get at with
more granularity through this resource
capacity accreditation process because
right now it is a pretty blunt
instrument
and we need to get much more specific
and granular About It by individual
technology and resource type and even
where it sits on the system and an
ability to to perform
uh representative monaster's question
thank you Mr chair
um
I hope I didn't misunderstand something
you said earlier and and and and perhaps
putting you on the spot and if I am I
apologize
um you I think said that
um kind of the industry industry's view
of Massachusetts overall policy
objective is decarbonization
yes correct good
um does the industry have a similar view
of New Hampshire I mean can you can you
put what new your view of New
Hampshire's policy objectives in a real
nugget like that so to to put it most
bluntly
um as I look across the region and again
our our footprint is the the Six States
I see it largely a north-south divide I
see Massachusetts Rhode Island and
Connecticut largely being driven by
decarbonization of course they want
reliability and of course they want
um uh competitive pricing for their
consumers but largely the driving force
being decarbonization as a top-line
policy standpoint and I look at a state
like New Hampshire as largely being
driven by economics and affordability
and it is the the challenges as we see
it is that New England electrically is a
single market and yet we have six
individual states with all the rights to
set their own policies and and resource
mix
but trying to figure out a way to create
a common market and a balancing of all
that
follow-up
um
could you characterize Vermont and Maine
just to complete the picture sure uh uh
so so Maine is is frankly a funny blend
I think of New Hampshire and
Massachusetts of decarbonization is an
explicit priority
however it is less aggressive in its
Pursuit as we see in some of the the
southern New England states
um Vermont is a very different and a
little bit of a funny Beast for us here
in New England Vermont is the only state
in the United States that does not have
a utility scale power plant it is the
only state without a fossil fuel power
plant and it by its nature then almost
entirely Imports its electricity Supply
both from Quebec and actually the
Seabrook Nuclear Station here under
long-term contract
um
I have a hard time putting Vermont in a
single box it is also the lowest
consumer of electricity of any state in
New England
representative Loki is recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman on the
transmission costs in the transmission
build it's kind of a double question one
of them is with a guaranteed rate of
return
um is there an incentive to over invest
or over build and then the second
question would be do these people when
they building have any risk whatsoever
so to ask answer the the second part
first uh the risk is extraordinarily low
um to to eat the cost of of any
increases or
um or delays as as part of that
transmission build out in terms of the
um the incentive to overbuild yes I I am
concerned that there is absolutely that
incentive and it puts a really
challenging burden on the regulator to
be able to provide the necessary
oversight to hold all of those
Investments to exactly what is necessary
or what may be prudent and the concern
being that as we look at some of those
individual state regulatory entities do
they have the expertise and capability
to fully do that and I
I think that is something that deserves
closer inspection
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um I'm wanting to
refer back I think to
representative Munn's earlier question
actually and then all the way back to
representative Thomas's
question at the beginning where he
asks and you responded about the um
you know what's driving the price
the cost increases of course you know
we've talked about money in the last few
days
and it's you know plainly the the input
costs you said the input costs to
generators uh can you
try and articulate the challenges that
you have in
the design of these Market instruments
when you are
um
representing and our system is blending
both kinds of generators where
with
nuclear and fossil well fossil fuel
generators mostly right that are
dominating the market
um there's significant input costs of
fuel ongoing costs of fuel uh and
obviously at the beginning there was
Capital costs required to build those
plants whereas with Renewables like
solar and wind
almost 100 percent of the cost is
capital investment at the beginning and
almost no cost
for decades is fuel
it's really challenging uh and you know
if you look on a slide nine here we we
try and break out what what is the fuel
mix that that was actually supplied in
2021 and unfortunately we don't yet have
the final numbers for 2022 so
um bear with me on on a little bit
um uh dated here but but if you look
um through it
um yes you know natural gas is is Far
and Away the largest single source of of
generation as as part of that as a as a
fossil fuel uh they have that that that
marginal cost that uh that input cost is
fuel and when the price of natural gas
goes up
um we we see that those costs go up
pretty dramatically on the flip side if
you look at kind of that green wedge
Renewables the orange wedge nuclear for
the most part and there are exceptions
but for the most part those are very
very low or even zero marginal cost
resources their fuel is a negligible
portion of the operation of of those
facilities that purple wedge net Imports
that is mostly existing inner ties we
have with Quebec and for the most part
again speaking broadly
that is largely Hydro electric as is
actually
most of that that renewal that green
Renewables wedge in New England so if if
rough Justice numbers I I add together
the Renewables the net Imports and the
nuclear then I come out with actually a
majority of the current system is
dispatched on a very low or even zero
marginal cost basis
um and from that I think in the energy
markets consumer see enormous value
because that that does hold that price
down and then really disciplines any
fossil fuel either natural gas or even
the the very small portion of oil and
coal that that is still relied on on
this region to only the portion that is
most efficient and most necessary to
meet demand in any given period of time
but as we look forward I think what
you're asking is
a little bit more of a philosophical
question of we've got some resources
that have very very low marginal cost
resources but the new ones have fairly
High upfront Capital costs to come into
the market we've got other resources
that may have much higher marginal costs
to perform in the market but relatively
low Capital cost to enter the market how
do we make all that work
really delicately
um and this is where
um I I I don't believe we should rely on
any one segment of our market and that
is to say the energy Market is dictated
by that marginal cost what is that final
fuel which then makes some of these
fossil fuels today based on the prices
that we see prevailing in the global
markets more expensive to operate
we then also must rely on this forward
capacity Market which is where those
Capital costs those upfront construction
and
operation and maintenance costs all must
be recovered
but similarly I don't know that we only
want to to rely on that and so we try
and blend those those two elements
together
um
hopefully as as as I've been able to to
try and weave in here and stayed at the
opening
um these markets are not perfect they
probably never will be but that is what
we're trying to achieve is that
appropriate balance all with then the
ultimate eye on making sure that this
blend of different financing and
different operating characteristics
provides a reliable and at least cost
competitive service while trying to
achieve the the broader State policy
mandates as they exist
thank you okay before I call on
representative munz I have a couple of
questions myself
you expressed some concern earlier about
over building in the transmission system
my understanding is that ISO New England
is the organization that oversees the
Planning and Building of transmission
it's not the individual states or or the
individual utilities that own that
transmission
system so
is it your
concern that ISO New England is over
building our regional transmission
system so to be clear ISO New England is
responsible for the planning of the
transmission system and then it is the
individual utilities who are designated
to do the building and put forward the
plans to implement some of those broader
directives from the iso and yes I
believe that the iso has both over
planned the transmission system and I am
concerned that the utilities in
implementing on both the Wholesale
Transmission so the big transmission
lines on 93 that you see going down the
highways as well as the more State
regulated distribution Network system
deserve closer oversight
thank you my second question earlier
today when ISO New England was here we
heard about the interconnection queue
and the interconnection queue apparently
at the moment is populated almost
entirely with wind resources and solar
resources there's virtually no
gas nuclear
or any other type of resource in the
interconnection queue
do you see that as a problem going
forward will the resources that are in
that queue be sufficient to provide the
region with the
double the amount of power that it needs
today
I believe that the iso interconnection
queue is a really helpful snapshot into
one version of what the future may look
like in that only a fraction of the
resources that are in the queue at any
given moment and that's true today just
as it was 20 years ago will ever
actually get built it and so today
clearly the signal for where New England
is is an exponential growth in some of
those resources that you highlighted the
one other segment that I see in a really
large scale on the Queue are battery
storage resources trying to enter the
market
whether that's sufficient to to meet our
future needs I have no idea and yet what
we're trying to do is figure out how do
we preserve and maximize the existing
infrastructure that we do have match it
with the new resources that may be
coming on into the market and cobbled
together from there a combination that
is sufficient to meet our our future
demand needs and certainly one of the
biggest challenges that we face over the
next decade decade plus is as we start
to see an acceleration in growth in
electrification
to transportation to home heating a
growth that I do believe will occur
a challenge for New England is it's
really hard to cite anything here
um
renewable conventional anything
and uh and we're going to have to
reconcile the
um the the long history and culture that
we have in this region of local control
over those processes with a regional
Marketplace and Regional needs for
energy demand
great thank you representative munz has
a question thank you Mr chairman and
that's a great segue to my question
um it has been suggested that um New
Hampshire to address some of these
challenges should
um decouple from ISO and go our own way
your thoughts
so to be really corny for a minute I
think we're the United States for a
reason and not the independent states
for a reason we work much better
together and just as New Hampshire
should not be expected to be
self-sufficient in oranges I do not
believe it makes sense for us to be
self-sufficient in any individual
commodity
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh just a quick
question you talked about earlier about
uh individual State policies with
Massachusetts number one policy if I
understand right is uh in
decarbonization has uh the
decarbonization policy of Massachusetts
and because we're all members of iso New
England has it had any effect plant
closures lack of or changing of policy
power capability affected the pricing or
availability of power in New Hampshire
foreign
I do believe that Massachusetts through
some of their state policies have had a
price impact on on the regional
electricity Market uh and in it's
difficult to pinpoint a plant closure on
any individual policy and and I would
hesitate to to do that but there is one
policy in particular as I look at it
which is that
um Massachusetts more than any other
state at least in in New England has a
separate carbon price above and beyond
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
of which all New England states
participate in that price is paid only
by carbon emitting power plants in
Massachusetts
that by its very nature will increase
the priced offers that those facilities
make into to the market and when those
plants are the the last facilities
needed to meet reliability yes that
means it creates a higher price for New
Hampshire and all the other states in
the region
it is
it is difficult to fully segregate the
impacts of an individual state
in the regional market overall
thank you very much
representative Reynolds has a
short compact question
thank you Mr chairman following on to
that
response we were in the previous uh ISO
New England's presentation
they showed us that
Energy Efficiency and distributed energy
resources have had a significant
downward effect on demand and therefore
price throughout the region
um
would you say that New Hampshire's
relative lack of
contribution of Energy Efficiency and
distributed energy resources have had an
upward effect on price
foreign
that is a difficult counter factual for
me to answer so let me try it this way
uh
I agree that
massachusetts's policies on on Energy
Efficiency have had a net impact of
lowering the amount of of resources that
are bought through the capacity markets
and have therefore had a a depressing
impact on the overall prices there
to the degree that any other state does
not have as aggressive Energy Efficiency
policies in place by its nature they're
going to be taking on a larger portion
of the uh the demand in the region than
they otherwise would and
bear the the costs associated with that
right
thank you representative Thomas Doug
Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for this
question uh do you handle any of our
hydro plants in the state yes the vast
majority of the hydro generation is
within our membership yes well
follow up uh good thank you so can you
um expand a little bit about their their
contribution and their future uh in this
state and and if they uh because I I
feel that they're important I'd like to
know what your thoughts are on their
longevity and continuity here I I
believe that hydropower has a critical
role to to play in this market both
today and and frankly probably more so
into the future as we look at a future
Market structure that requires
flexibility
requires an ability to deliver
irrespective of
um uh most weather and uh has an ability
to perform over long periods of time
Beyond just any one day cycle or one day
event I I think Hydro particularly
larger hydro and aggregation of a number
of smaller Hydra facilities uh is is
going to be a critical resource for the
region
follow-up
thank you uh so so my other question was
what's their
prognosis for for progressing here and
anything that we can do to help them
so I I think part of the challenge is
that the vast majority of the hydro
electric generation not just in New
Hampshire but but across New England
um does not receive some of the the
other direct
Contracting and subsidies that we do see
in other states and like other
facilities that that do not have that
that benefit their economics suffer
um in the market as a result and so I
think in the long-term preservation of
those facilities and making sure that
not only can we keep them as they are
today but do the necessary reinvestment
in the facilities to maintain their
operations that means turning changing
out the turbines
um uh every 20 years or so
particularly for hydro you get erosion
in in the dams by its nature with with
water having to to reinvest in that I
think it's critical that we ensure that
there is economic pricing coming out of
that and feel fill this hole of how do
we blend this bifurcated Market we have
of
Revenue guarantees for some
and pure Live and Die in the market for
others we have to find a way to bridge
that Gap and I believe in doing so Hydro
along with frankly nuclear and some of
the other resources that provide
critical resources
are the ones that are going to be most
sensitive to to that
representative merner has a question
hi nice to see you I had a long summer
with you
uh in August that was a record sale
obviously for the billions that was just
sold on the Connecticut River for all
the hydros so obviously they don't a lot
more than we know what uh Quebec just
paid for those hydros that came out to I
think 500 and somewhat dollars per
megawatt
so and it's good to see you
representative uh uh uh what
representative merner is referring to is
that um a portfolio of hydro facilities
called Great River Hydro
um uh announced that it was being bought
by Hydro Quebec
um uh for a a significant sum as as part
of that I think there's a couple things
to keep in mind
um one is that um uh hydroquobec has
um
to put it politely I I had an
interesting time of it in New England
um over the last decade or so
particularly in New Hampshire and I'm
just going to leave that one there uh
and uh on top of that as as
um I I was trying to um uh to emphasize
in response to representative Thomas's
um question I think hydrogeneration is
very well positioned
um uh in the future of of this market
and I think when you look at the
combination of those two elements and
the premium to come into this Market at
scale
I I think that's where you see
um a transaction price like that um
start to come out
um but yes it I certainly uh recognize
the uh the wide eyes that that many had
in seeing that
yeah the the evaluation of facilities
the the timing was was uh was ironic on
that one
representative lewicki has a question
okay thank you Mr chairman and thank you
um
can you give us some estimate for how
many Hydro properties in New Hampshire
are unexploited because my observation
is that there's a big pile of bricks
next to almost any good one I you know
they have tens of megawatts that we
could still exploit hundreds of
megawatts or
any idea
I hesitate to give you any direct answer
on that one because I I truly don't have
um a a good enough understanding of what
that that could look like
um
I know you know new Hydro is really hard
to to permit and cite it's a years-long
process even to re-license facilities
and each of these Hydro facilities have
a finite operating license
is a years-long process working with the
host communities and overseen by the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
to develop in any meaningful large-scale
new facilities or bring back into the
market facilities that may have shut
down
I'm not going to say never but I think
is an enormous challenge in this market
well we don't want to uh to keep you
folks any longer I know you uh both have
lots of other activities that you need
to engage in so we want to thank you
profusely for being here for providing
some great information
and for visiting with us it's great to
see you both and I'm sure we'll see you
again in the not too distant future so
thank you thank you very much
and with that we come to the end of our
committee activity for today I would
remind all members to consult the
calendar that will be published this
evening for the schedule for Monday and
Tuesday of this coming week
to go over it quickly with you I'll
remind you that we have on Monday
morning a presentation by the puc from 9
to 11. from 11 to 11 30 we'll do some
we'll finish up some of the committee
business that we didn't complete on
organization day
representative Bernardi will explain the
process of executive session during that
half hour period
and then after lunch we start hearing
bills so we will hear four bills
on the afternoon of Monday
and then on Tuesday we come back at nine
o'clock and we have a presentation by
the community Power Association or
Community power Coalition of New
Hampshire from nine to nine from nine to
ten thirty and then we will hear bills
at 10 30 1 2 and 3 o'clock
and then at four o'clock we will have an
executive session our first executive
session of the year
we have five early bills and we will be
hearing three of those on Monday and
Tuesday and we will be
um
passing judgment on those bills an
executive session on Tuesday
so that's the schedule for next week
there will be a similar schedule for the
week following that and for the first
three weeks of February
and by the time we get to February 21st
we'll we'll have heard public hearings
hopefully on all 40 of the bills
assigned to this committee
so that's the schedule going forward go
home get a good night's sleep have a
nice weekend and we'll see you next
Monday
with that I'm going to adjourn this
committee session